did you guys you got into fitness a lot
recently huh yeah I mean on this on the
last tour you know what happened was
that like
I always
like do it somewhat right because you
guys have done that uh sober October for
a while but even like before that it was
always like I mean that would be a
another time but I would get like to a
certain point and then I would have the
mentality of like oh I I got there like
it's almost like the race is over like
I'm done like now I'm good
like 10 times or more and so that what
happens is you when you go like I'm done
you just kind of retreat back to old
habits and you get out of shape
and then all of a sudden you're like oh
[__] how'd this happen again and then
you you go I'm gonna do it again and
then you go all right I'm gonna work out
and eat clean and then you lose weight
and you start to get and then you go oh
I did I got to this number again all
right I feel and then you just kind of
pull back and so it really was that I
got frustrated by that and I had this I
had
I had gotten I was I was on tour
and um we were working out on tour but
not really like
dialed in on food and the tour was like
aggressive like Non-Stop and I remember
that I got to back to LA to shoot this
thing I was shooting this pilot
I had written and I I was I was covering
the whole production and I went I
remember I was in the uh the Wardrobe
fitting for it and I was like [__] this
is like I feel like I'm going back like
in in the fitting the clothes I was like
oh this sucks and then I left there like
after that week and I was like I have to
take this more seriously but the
difference is is that I no longer go if
I see
a number that I like on a scale that
means I'm good it's just I I realized
that you have to do it like that there
is no end right it's just continuous
right it's like it's something that you
just if it's about goals you just have
to set new goals you know like if you
you can't go like oh if I see this
number I'm I'm at the weight I like okay
you have to set new fitness goals like
you have to go well this month is about
ah you know like cardio stuff or this
month I want to see if I can do 200
push-ups a day like you have to set goal
that's what I I mean that's so that's
what happened for you had you been doing
that before in your life setting like I
mean I know we have sometimes
subconsciously we set goals we don't
realize and we have some of that going
on in our general life but have you ever
done it that specifically before we were
like I'm gonna set a goal uh I've kind
of loosely I would say you know like hey
this month let's go let's go after this
type of thing and yeah things like like
in sober October but this was also the
time where I was like you know this
really as like cliche as it sounds can
be like a lifestyle change and now I
realized how much I am affected not just
physically mentally emotionally by and
in a good way by my like working out a
lot and like waking up
getting my my stuff together going to
the gym right away and I'm like I'm just
having a better day I'm just happier
yeah I'm moving around better I look
better I feel like so I just go
I feel like I have better uh creative
days you know like it's all kind of tied
together yeah it's it's tied together so
I just made it like
part of what I do it's like you know
I just I I know that I want to eat
certain types of food that are good for
me and by the way I'm not saying this
like I am the most strict dude and don't
ever like but I'm just like there's just
so much more oh yeah clean eating yeah
and um and I like that I like the
workouts I like it you know I like being
active and I just feel like
I'm very fortunate in that I have a
full-time trainer so yeah I'm I know I'm
I'm not right not everybody has that I
totally understand that it's a huge
Advantage so sometimes people will be
like well yeah of course you can do that
if you I'm like yeah that's I'm I'm very
lucky that I can do it but you also just
have to want that in your life yeah I
ran into well I ended up befriending uh
Jason Momoa Aquaman oh yeah in in New
Zealand wow and that was really fun and
I hung out with him for another day
don't swim or anything no we we went to
a bar and we hung out with like I don't
know a group for like 10 hours dang but
he couldn't have been like he's a real
down to earth guy yeah we met we met at
the hotel gym no that's cool he was like
I'll crouched down you make you look
taller I was like cool man
um oh you look pretty happy right it was
fun we had we had a fun time
um
yeah you know and then Izzy came out in
Auckland too he I feel like he comes in
he's a really special guy he's a he's a
cool uh man there's something really
interesting about him there's something
really amazing about new zealanders in
general there is there is yeah and I
think
he has a really
as if Fighters are fascinating to sign
up for that lifestyle you know what I
mean like yeah to be like I'm gonna I'm
gonna do battle for a living
that was two tour that was like in 2019
but yeah he he came again in this most
recent tour and um I just uh
I just enjoy the guy's energy you know
just being around 100 just being around
him and very inspirational whether he
wins or loses he's very inspirational a
lot of these Fighters are like that
there's something about a lot of them
whether they win or lose because you
just value so much that they even could
do it because they're they're actually
really putting it you know what it is
like inherently human beings we respect
stakes and if you're a fighter the
stakes are very clear like you're you're
putting your your physical body on the
line yeah to to win or lose and so
everybody we we just respect the fact
that like you're gonna like punch and
kick and like you know to your [__]
face and like this this could have like
real lasting effects so we just respect
it so much but I like that dude's energy
um and and I do find it inspiring to be
around them I like him a lot yeah hope
you enjoyed that video and you can watch
another and you can watch this one you
can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one